so what are the junior doctors asking
for their pay can range from just over
29 000 pounds to 58 000 pounds a year
with the average about 55 000 pounds a
year the British Medical Association is
asking for a pay rise of 35 to bring
salaries back to 2008 to 2009 levels
calling this pay restoration
between then and 2022 in cash terms
Junior doctors pay Rose by nearly 20
percent but prices have risen much more
by how much is open to debate the BMA
uses the retail price index of inflation
which suggests Prices rose about 58 in
that time period by contrast the
Consumer Price Index which Remains the
most common measure of inflation
particularly for pay negotiations Rose
40 between 2008 and 2022. this would
mean that Junior doctors pay fell 16 in
that time compared to the 26 percent
that the BMA says taking a 19 pay rise
to restore it
oh now the health secretary Steve
Barkley says he stands ready to talk but
says he can't meet their demands as they
stand we want to reach a fair and
reasonable settlement with Junior
doctors we recognize the hugely
important role that they play Within the
NHS that's why we stand ready to have
meaningful and constructive talks with
them as we have had with other health
unions as we have in terms of responding
at the budget to concerns from doctors
regarding their pensions so we are ready
to have discussions with them but
clearly a demand for 35 over 20 000
pounds for some Junior doctors is not
fair or reasonable and that is why we've
not been able to make progress so far
but we want to engage constructively we
recognize Junior doctors have been under
significant pressure particularly from
the pandemic and we want to work with
them to find a fair and reasonable
settlement
Matthew Thompson is at University
College London Hospital with the latest
spread dismay across the country the
papers are full of stories Sky News have
been reporting on a number of cases of
people who've perhaps been waiting weeks
months for appointments for crucial
operations people living with chronic
pain for example and those are being
canceled this week and that is clearly
having a real terms impact on the
quality of life of many thousands of
people right across the country I have
put that directly to a number of people
on the picket line behind me this
morning and they have all said to a man
to a woman that they're sorry they
recognize the impact that the strikes
are having but they all point to a piece
of work done by the Royal College of
emergency medicine at the start of the
year which said that the current state
of the NHS and delays to Emergency Care
are seeing 500 people a week dying
unnecessarily they say that the current
system is causing harm to patients and
so they've felt obliged to do something
about it and that's why they're on
strike even if they can accept that
patients are suffering I do say though I
mean it's just one patient among many
thousands but a woman came out a short
time ago with a a appointment leaflet
saying I've had my appointment canceled
today and I thought she was going to
give the protesters an earful but then
she said and it's Steve Barkley's fault
now look that's just one example but
there is you can hear the hong King as
well we're on busy Houston Road you can
hear that they're honking in support of
the picket line there is a degree of
public support out there even in spite
of the widespread disruption the doctors
here are in fine voice they've actually
been singing songs most of the morning
with witty tag lines like don't blame it
on inflation don't blame it on recession
don't blame it on the doctors blame it
on the Barclay but behind all the humor
is a serious message they feel that for
15 years or so they've been underpay
they've had real terms pay cuts we can
argue about whether that's measured by
RPI or CPI as you were pointing out but
the fact remains they have had a cut
they want to see that addressed by the
government the government for its part
you just heard Steve Martin you say they
think the demands are totally
unreasonable and militant